le vaccin en russe spoutnik v n'a
toujours pas reçu l'approbation de
l'agencé européenne des médicaments
cette question a été évoquée par le
ministre russe des affaires étrangères
sergueï lavrov et son homologue de saint
marin lors d'une rencontre sans mara est
l'un des rares pays européens qui
utilisent le vaccin russes ont fait le
point avec notre correspondante à moscou
vera goffman
la russie préconise une approche
professionnelle et non politisée à
l'égard des vaccins a déclaré le chef de
la diplomatie russe sergueï lavrov lors
d'une conférence de presse conjointe
avec son homologue du saint marin le cas
beccari en visite de travail à moscou le
ministre russe s'est plaint d'un
traitement partial du remède russes dans
l'union européenne joue propose
d'écouter
on a entendu de nombreuses déclarations
des dirigeants européens selon
lesquelles il faut s'orienter vers les
vaccins 6dans tôt notamment la président
de la commission européenne au sol à van
der leyen a fait de telles déclarations
on a entendu également qu'en france au
début de cette année on nous avait
publiquement accusé au plus haut niveau
la chine et nous de pratiquer une
stratégie d'agression vaccinale et ainsi
de suite et sur
donc on voit une certaine partialité
or notre ministère de la santé nos
scientifiques sont en contact avec la
commission européenne et l'agencé
européenne des médicaments
nous prononçons pour que ces contacts
soit entretenu de façon très
professionnelle sans aucune politisation
de son côté le secrétaire d'état san
marinais aux affaires étrangères le cab
et carey a défendu une approche
pragmatique des questions vaccinale
toute entière tournée vers la lutte
contre le virus et non polluée par des
considérations politiques
écoutez que la chine ça donnerait b
gouverneur est costaud momie tolède et
cheese ionis ou là
soula je crois qu'il ne devrait pas y
avoir de politisation c'est aux
scientifiques de parler et à la science
piccolo samarie une femme au japon la
soignante à la litanie son piquet jr
est un état couleurs pour sa neutralité
c'est ainsi nous avons justement un
exemple parfait de neutralité watier
note il est allé à bien mon chemin et
cria mais se manque et des bas benoît
sotchi et
de bonheur est à l'évidence scientifique
vaccin lui même ne peut faire l'objet
d'aucune spéculation c'est une question
de science je pense que l'utilisation du
vaccin devraient être plus étendue plus
vite le monde pour améliorer sa capacité
de fournir des vaccins ses citoyens au
mieux ce sera dur mais tout le monde ne
peut conditionner des machines à l'autre
tantôt prématurément à ce qu'une fille
jerry west ham à la terre près des trois
quarts de la population du saint marin
un micro état enclavé au nord-est de
l'italie ont été vaccinés avec le
spoutnik fait depuis le mois de février
une vaccination rendue possible par le
fait que saint marin n'est pas membre de
l'union européenne ou le spoutnik les
attend toujours un agrément de la part
de l'agencé européenne des médicaments